there is
a major threat from Q Anon though it
isn't just uh Insurrection it isn't just
playful ideas about wacky conspiracy
theories
there are other elements that have that
have human affected impact
this headline is a tragedy
from The New York Times look I'm I'm a
father
and to
foreign to think about the State of Mind
of this man who killed his kids
with a spear gun
because of Q Anon
[Music]
it's remarkable I don't understand how
someone
can go through with this and be
convinced of things that are so out of
this world
reading from The New York Times
surf instructor killed his children and
claimed Q Anon made him do it FBI says a
California servant instructor confessed
to killing his two children with a spear
fishing gun after abducting them telling
investigators that his belief in the
conspiracy theories known as Q Anon made
him do it the authority said on
Wednesday
the father Matthew Taylor Coleman of
Santa Barbara
drove his two two-year-old son and ten
month old daughter to Mexico over the
weekend and fatally shot him on Monday
according to an FBI investigator
in a nine page criminal affidavit that
was filed in U.S District Court in Los
Angeles on Wednesday the FBI special
agent wrote that Mr Coleman told the
authorities that he knew what he did was
wrong
but that it was the only course of
action that would save the world M
Coleman stated that he believed his
children were going to grow into
monsters
so we had to kill them
the special agent Jennifer Bannon wrote
She Wrote This M Coleman explained that
he was enlightened by Q Anon an
Illuminati conspiracy theories and was
receiving visions and signs revealing
that his wife AC
essed serpent DNA and had passed it on
to his children Mr Coleman described
himself as an inherent of Q Anon the
pro-trump conspiracy movement whose
followers hold closely hold falsely
excuse me that a cabal of Democrats and
Coastal Elites engage in pedophilia and
worship Satan the conspiracy movement
has been the subject of warnings by the
FBI and its followers would resort to
violence and they are right
the FBI was right the warnings were
right the Homeland Security Department
is right
this guy took his kids to Mexico and
shot him in the chest
with a spear gun
imagine the agony the death
the suffering that's not a quick that's
not a quick ending to a life
their father
did this
Q Anon is not just a playful
set of goofy thoughts
it's not
it is nothing but virulent
and sickening and dangerous and now two
children won't grow
to be adults
and this guy's gonna go to prison for
the rest of his life
a mother doesn't have her kids anymore
because of Q Anon